A second method for
dealing with missing data is to impute
new values where values
in the data are missing.
Now if you're not familiar with
the term imputation, in statistics it's
the process of substituting values in
the data where the values are missing.
Which basically means that when we
impute values, we are making them up.
Some statisticians might not
appreciate that terminology, but
it's important to realize just what
we're doing when we impute data.
We are creating fake data in order to
develop a model that makes sense and
is as close to reality as we can get it.
The last part of that statement
is what's most important.
We want to develop a model that gets
as close to reality as we can get.
So let's go back to our
example dataset and
see what it might mean to impute
data in our survey results.